[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in [music] this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. We're honored to
continue and
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program [music] is for educational
purposes only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music] nor is it intended to
take the place of your primary care
physician. Testimonials [music] are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual sharing their testimony.
Results vary and may not be typical. We
do not make any claims regarding health
or income. As an empowered [music]
individual, you do have options
available. We are honored to have the
founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding [music] us with the
best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music]
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual sharing their [music]
testimony. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make [music] any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have the founding father of the science
of epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. [music] The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual sharing
their testimony. Results vary and may
not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered [music] individual, you do
have options available. We are honored
to have the founding father of the
science of epigenetics guiding us with
the best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
[music] only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music] nor is it intended to
take the place of your primary care
physician. Testimonials [music]
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual sharing their testimony.
[music] Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health [music] or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have the founding father of the science
of epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
>> [music]
>> Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
[music] only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials are [music] shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results [music]
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
nor is it intended to [music] take the
place of your primary care physician.
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual sharing
their testimony. [music] Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health or income.
As an [music] empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best.
Everybody, let's open up that door and
let everybody in. Dr. W is calling me
saying, "What's the delay? What's wrong?
What's going on?" Um but hello and
welcome to Daily with Doc and thank you
doc for calling and checking. It just
shows how much you care as yes even the
best of times have technical
difficulties but we are just going to go
h and keep on going. So thank you so
much everybody for joining us here on
Daily with Doc. My name is Becca Dukes
and as the hostess of this show and also
the director of student services for the
Institute of Holistic Health, it is my
honor and privilege to be able to create
a resource not only for our students but
our community and you as a whole. So
today we are honored to be able to have
one of our amazing guests that we've had
in the past. We get lots of requests
wanting to know when's she going to be
back because what she talks about is
affecting millions if not billions of
people around the world. And we are
going to be shedding some light on how
food
interacts with the receptors and
transmitters within the brain which then
can lead to pain.
So, I'm super excited to be able to have
with us and oh, before I get started on
that, I got to keep my SK keep my
housekeeping going. If you were invited
by somebody specific, make sure you get
back with them. they took the time and
cared enough about you, knowing that
there's something within today's program
that is going to speak to you in giving
you empowerment and hope that there is a
better health journey waiting for you.
So, if you're not in any pain and you're
not experiencing any health crisis,
you're listening because you probably
know who is experiencing those type of
things. So please share this program
with others as we are doing our part to
help individuals understand
what is causing poor health conditions
and not only understand them but provide
solutions.
So today we have with us one of my good
friends, my dear friends I consider a
sister who is absolutely fantastic,
amazing Ivonne Ray. She's functional
medicine practitioner. She's a nutrition
practitioner. She uses microcurrent and
is a microcurrent pain specialist. She
is boardcertified.
Is that board certified with
microcurrent pain as a pain specialist
or
>> yes
>> amunotherapy for the brain?
>> I am certified for amino acid therapy
for the brain as well.
>> Okay. So she has lots of board
certifications in addition to be being a
certified holistic health coach. Now she
is former military and she has worked
with the painfree forlife beta testing
research where microcurrent protocols
are developed erasing pain holistic
centers where she assists in training
interns and as the nutritional director.
She's a team member at B Theta Wellness
Brain Health Center in Sacramento. As an
educator, she teaches weekly classes on
nutrition and the use of frequency
devices to expedite the healing curve.
She also volunteers to work with other
clinicians to broaden their scope of
knowledge and research. Quarterly, she
travels and presents the impact of
nutrition frequency devices for natural
alternatives
at home pain relief. So, it is my honor
and privilege to have Ivonne here with
us. She is such an amazing individual
and with a heart that truly truly is for
helping individuals find
what they're looking for when other
pract uh modalities
mainstream have not provided that.
Ivonne, thank you so much for joining us
today.
>> I am I'm honored to be here. I really
am. It's a delight to just bring
something um that oftent times you know
these therapies are hidden just like you
and doc and this whole community often
recognize with nutrition how nutrition
many of the therapies of nutrition are
hidden.
Oh, absolutely. And one thing that I
love about what you do is it's not just
a therapy for this or it's not just
nutrition for this,
but you really marry the two, but on top
of that, you're teach you teach, you
instruct,
you are an educator. So whenever we
understand the way things are working, I
think it has an even greater impact than
when we just tell somebody to do
something. Without them understanding,
they're not going to know the importance
of why they need to do what is being
recommended.
So agreed. Um I think you've heard this
story, you know, about me before. Uh I
asked so many questions that you know in
in Sunday school I got asked to sit out
in the hallway on the bench. I think the
teacher was thought I was trying to
challenge her but you know I had some
information but I was looking for um you
know to line those threads together of
what she said to what I knew. Um
actually even even in the military um
while when I was in boot camp uh I asked
one too many questions and um uh those
girls you know they actually tied my
hands behind my back. They were like we
just want to get out of here.
Well, I love the fact that you don't let
things like that stop you from moving
forward and finding the answers that
you're looking for.
So so many people are dealing with pain.
Can you enlighten us on what causes
pain? What is what's underlying cause of
pain? What are things that
add to that inflammation?
And then let's go into some of the
solutions and things to consider when
we're going through including our food.
>> Certainly. Um well I think it's
important here's I'm going to uh give
you diff different pieces of
information. Um the first thing is when
you have pain
uh unless the tissue is uh going into an
atrophy state um kind of going asleep
you know kind of dying
uh there is usually pain and the
precursor to pain is inflammation.
So in the presence of inflammation that
will bring about pain. Um and then the
next thing you want to be aware of is
there's different types of
uh fibers that
pain fibers that will represent
different types of pain. They're called
A, B, and C fibers and they carry
different type uh types of pain. Uh
typically um an A fiber is on the
mileing um um um the mileination.
Uh that'll be pain that is often sharp
um sharp sensations. It's fast. Uh I
just experienced that the other day.
Don't know what I did, but my shoulder.
Ouch. Uh B fibers and then C fibers.
Actually C fibers they say most people
have that uh dull um slow or burning
sensation. Um and those are typically
associated with sea fibers. They're achy
and lingering as well. So there's a
couple different types of pain to start
with. And in the context of what I do
using microcurrent and then other
frequency devices
um
if I can drop that inflammation,
I can move that pain and the body can
begin to heal because in the presence of
inflammation,
the body can't actually heal. I want you
to think about those tissues. um you
know like on your um [clears throat]
phone uh we can go for those emojis and
there'll be the fire emoji, right? Uh so
imagine underneath that fire emoji,
you've got some cells,
you know, they're screaming, right?
Well, we want to come in and first drop
the inflammation.
And I'll use my microcurrent.
Uh I have other devices um like light um
stem cell
um uh terraertz uh scalar also known as
quantum. And just so you know quantum
the definition for quantum is small or
technically it's so small it's
invisible. Uh but I'll use these devices
first and then because in the presence
of inflammation when we're trying to get
our nutrition in many times those cells
are so inflamed it can be hard for it to
reach out and quench itself. Does that
make sense?
>> I think it makes sense to me. Um you're
making you're making a lot of sense
actually. So folks, really pay attention
because she's going deep and looking at
this in a way that others have not
explained it to you most likely. So
please continue Ivonne.
Um so uh you know again there's just a
little bit about you know what is pain
uh the and this is just very brief the
different types of pain that could be
going on. Uh and now just so you know
there will be let's say um medications.
So let me back up for a minute. We are
spiritual beings. We're electromag
magnetic beings. Uh we're chemical.
We're emotional.
The body will respond to sound to light.
All of these things can bring benefit to
the body.
um or if in the wrong setting or amount
they can do harm as well. uh I typically
work on the body's electrical of the
system
and so by using that I can quickly drop
inflammation
and then for me I always get them
started on nutrition so that we can
rebuild
that missing tissue. uh none of the
devices that uh as far as I see it any
practitioner uses
can
replace missing tissue. What it can do
is it can take that burden off the body
and then we must add adequate amounts
for the rebuild of that tissue.
So Ivonne,
we've heard Dr. Wallak talking about
being able to rebuild and restore.
Now with that,
we can do it through nutrition or
nutrition plays a big part or what part
does the nutrition pay play into it? But
most importantly,
well, I don't think anything's more
important than quality nutrition, but
how are foods affecting our ability to
be able to break free?
So,
first you asked, what part does
nutrition play and then
how does it help us break free? Um,
for starters,
in my opinion, for most of us, it's the
food that is the causation of the pain.
Now, let me let me back that up. There
are there are several things that can
cause inflammation. Let's say, you know,
you've got tonitis. Tenitis can be one
viral. So, there could be a a type of
pathogen that's creating the
inflammation. Um, it can be structural.
Uh, I had an accident or much like when
we're um looking at it's all in your
head. You can look at that picture of
the skull and we see what a normal skull
looks like and then we see one that is
um in well technically it's it's it's
degragating. The tissue is degragating
but for bones it will actually get
thicker. Now, it's not stronger, but
it's thicker in size. So, think about
it. My skull gets thicker and it begins
to impinge upon any one of those
um 24
cranial nerves. Just as a reminder, you
have two pairs of 12. They all originate
in the brain. They run down the
cervical. They continue. Six will come
to the right arm, six to the left.
They'll continue down the trunk, and
then they wrap around and they're
innervated with every organ in the
trunk. They continue to go down the
legs, six to the right, six to the left,
all the way down to the feet.
Um, so
if if you're eating or let let me back
up. So, if you're in pain, there's a
couple causations of the pain. And
again, uh just to back up, that'll be
either viral or pathogen. A type of
pathogen can cause um inflammation.
Um uh uh structurally and you could have
had some uh type of an accident. So,
that would also usually be considered
structural. And then there is what you
know many call aging. Uh we would also
call that degragation because the tissue
begins to um wear thin um you know like
the myelinated sheath will become holy,
right? They call them lesions. I'm not
really sure why it calls a lesion
because the tissue is missing, but um it
all it almost to me sounds like there's
something that's been added. That that'd
be a great question for Doc, huh? Um,
>> that is a great question because I was
thinking the same thing.
>> Yes. Yeah. But, you know, so when they
tell you that there are lesions, um, you
know, anyway, I I see it differently and
even when, you know, I had assisted in
autopsies while I'd never seen a lesion.
Uh, we would see other types of lesions
and there was um, you know, added tissue
to to the body. So uh when you have pain
what you have to first identify what's
the causation of the pain what's the
causation of the inflammation and then
begin to recognize like I use tools
because those tools will shorten
that healing curve. They're going to
quickly reduce the burden [snorts] from
the body and then I'm going to flood the
body with high doses of therapeutic
clinical nutrition. There's different
names that people, you know, use those
by, but ultimately it is for the rebuild
of that tissue. And um so many of us our
food source even when we're really
trying our food source is not
it's not adequate. Uh we know that you
know our soils are deplete of minerals.
So you're talking to somebody who in my
opinion we have to supplement to rebuild
missing tissue. And that missing tissue
oftent times is directly related to your
pain and going all the way back just
depending upon if that's an A, B or C
fiber pain.
Well, actually when I think about it and
I reflect back on the people that I've
helped with quote unquote lesions
that then they go for their scans and
the lesions are not there anymore. It
totally makes sense. that when you give
the nutrition and it's rebuilding
and replacing those missing pieces that
the lesions would no longer be there.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's that's fascinating. I love
>> I mean think you know when when they say
lesions and and so like I actually you
know have a couple MS um clients right
now um you know that
um insulator the myelin sheath. So if
this is the nerve, you got the insulator
around it. It actually looks like Swiss
cheese, but yet the client understands
it, the patient understands it as
lesions, like there's something
additional there. Um, and so again,
while I haven't actually seen that,
lesions technically are missing tissue.
So
>> I love that.
>> So I ask, "What's your tissue issue?"
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Well, I love that reference to to
Swiss cheese.
>> Yeah,
absolutely. It's a visual. It's a
visual. And and and if you understand I
have something missing, you know, you
are more likely to really um begin to
I'm going to use the word buy in because
that's what had to happen to me. you
know, former military, um, you know, I
was kind of the Jane Fonda of the
hospitals and, you know, thought I was
pretty fit while nutrition was very slim
in that because I don't know why often
times nutrition and fitness don't seem
to go together. But,
uh, I, you know, and and I was working
at the hospitals, I truly believed that
you could get everything you need in
those four food groups. Uh, but but we
can't. And so it took a while for that
you know understanding that buyin to
happen but and I think when people
understand that tissue is has missing or
is degragated. Oh let me add to that to
rebuild it. Uh if you think about
um in your um area probably just like
everybody else's at night
when the freeways are um not as you know
compacted with cars our construction
crew will come out there to repair the
bridges, the roadways etc. Um our body
does that similarly at night but it can
only rebuild
what you have given it. So if you didn't
bring enough you know cement or bricks
to the to the construction site you know
that part of it isn't going to be
happening. That's how I see things.
>> I love it. Fantastic. So, so how is it
that the food plays into this
>> plays into
breaking
>> breaking free from pain?
>> Well, let's let's first just start with
this. Um,
we know that there are four basic tissue
types of the body. And just as a
reminder, that is epithelial, muscle,
nerve, um, and connective tissue. And
those four, type this into your Google
when you're ready, and you can check it
out later, but the four basic tissues of
the body. Uh, well, Doc has put together
this, but in a way that, you know, the
layman can kind of sort of understand.
And that's the four health categories
hard tissue, soft tissue, um digestive
and uh I call it endocrine but but blood
sugar which includes hormone and
endocrine system. So just know that all
falls in that. And um
uh uh so when you first look at the four
basic tissue types and if you get to
know those, you're going to understand
the four categories and immediately
you'll know when you put food in this
pie hole.
you know, if it's going to bring
wellness and rebuild or is this going to
cause damage? Is this going to rob the
body of nutrients? You know, when I was
in the military,
um, uh, I want you to just think of, you
know, defensively,
the body has its own department of
defense. You know, we have the Army, the
Navy, the Air Force, the Marines, uh the
Coast Guard, and they're in the
different areas of the body and the type
that are. But think about this. If um
if I put something in this pie hole and
uh okay, a battalion is um 800 Marines.
All right? And
I put in, you know, uh, gluten, which is
an inflammatory, whether you're
sensitive or not, it is an inflammatory.
It does create a biofilm, which smothers
the villi. Again, whether you're
sensitive or intolerant or not, our
wheat is not what it once was. So if I
put that in, half of the troops are
going to go over there to try to defend
what I just put in. So now I've robbed
myself of getting those other that other
half of the battalion to help either I
look at it this way. Here's enough for
me to main uh just survive the day. just
survive or am I getting enough nutrients
in to maintain my current status?
Am I taking in enough to thrive? Most of
us want to thrive. You know, if we look
at
uh the the labels on many of the
um
our
>> like the nutritional panels. Yes, it'll
give you the absolute minimum.
We're talking you want to frontload the
body, get in enough to rebuild the the
the missing tissue, and then you can
come back to a maintenance load. Uh but
again, just coming back to your original
question, you know, um uh how does how
does the food play in? because the food
can either cause the problem
uh in many ways
ultimately it's robbing the body of the
nutrition because again those nutrients
will first defend
before it'll it'll give you enough to
survive the day. Um but there's
certainly barely any maintenance going
on or even rebuilding. Does that make I
mean does that make sense? You like that
analogy? I do like that analogy. And so,
does it make a difference
with the times that we eat food and the
times that we take our nutrition?
Because we do have a question in the
chat right now says, "So, should we take
things like collagen at night?"
And going back to your reference of the
the work crews rebuilding at night.
[clears throat]
>> Yeah. So I you know there's a there's a
um there are different um ideas on when
you should take nutrients.
That is not an area that I feel
confident enough to tell you with
absolute certainty. But what I can tell
you is that your body needs to rest. So
many will suggest you know stop eating 3
hours or so before the body before you
go to bed. And the purpose for that is
uh it takes a good you know two three
we've seen I I've seen research that
says 5 hours you know for your body to
digest food. it will be about the
individual's ability to um you know
metabolize the food. So let's just say
you do go to bed um or you eat shortly
before going to bed. Your body is now
working
when it really needs to be resting and
then rebuilding.
Uh the other thing about that working is
um
you know uh think about
I want to go to bed. I need my body to
be sleeping but it's digesting. And many
talk about research shows us the actual
energy output that the body does to
digest. I've seen many state it's like
climbing a hill. Not a mountain. That'd
be pregnancy,
but like climbing like climbing a hill.
So, I'm going to bed, but I just put
something here. And while I'm not in
motion, your digestive track is, and
it's climbing a hill to digest whatever
it is that you just put in. So I think
that you know uh we can certainly you
know uh get a panel and I'm happy to get
some more um uh direct answers but
that's how I best understand that. Was
that helpful?
>> I think I think that's helpful because
absolutely I mean if you're if you're
eating right before going to bed your
body's still working. it is. And think
about the amount of work that your body
does just to digest.
So, let's talk about that whole digest
part. You covered nut the gluten,
whether you are sensitive to it or not.
Thank you so much for whoever put me up.
Um, and how it is creating inflammation
within the body. Do you have other
things, other food choices or group
categories that are creating more pain
or adding to that inflammation?
>> Certainly. Um
well, if we just want to look at the um
you know the good food, bad food list,
the first thing you want to recognize is
there's all kinds of good food, bad food
lists. just depends upon what you're
focused on. Some will focus on night
shades, um sugar content,
gluten, right?
Uh but if we're just looking at what
most of us are already familiar with, um
just another one outside of gluten, uh
well, oh gosh, let's talk about corn,
soil, any of the GMOs,
um any of the
uh synthetic sugars, you know, many
people think, if you remember this, I
want you to think about this with the
gluten trend that's going on now.
They're taking a small piece of food and
wrapping it around all of this other
synthetic processed stuff and saying
here here is you know um here's a
pumpkin pie. I you know
um
there's uh there's really no value
there. So, yes, there's many others. Um,
I'm going to just ask you to maybe even
give me one uh cuz my brain is probably
moving a little too swiftly. [laughter]
So, you you mentioned like sugar
substitutes.
>> Sugar in general
can cause inflammation. Is that correct?
>> Too much. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I mean, our body needs a little bit.
Well, well, so let's let's talk about
this. What does your body need? Your
body is made up of proteins and fats.
And you get enough proteins and fats,
you can make your own carbohydrates.
Sugar is a uh carbohydrate. Obviously,
we need various times different
um uh carbohydrate load for the workload
that we're doing. Um, so, you know, I've
seen levels as low as, you know, don't
don't take in any more than 20 grams of
sugar. Um, a day, uh, the average they
say is consuming something like, I mean,
I'm seeing 100 plus grams of sugar a
day. That certainly is not beneficial
for the body. And if we look at uh I'm
trying to remember the guy's name. Is it
Clive McKay? Uh give me a minute to
remember, but they did some research on
um sugar. And and I'm going to
transition into the addiction of sugar.
When you're taking in that much sugar,
it will shut down numerous things
happening.
um whether it's uh um transference of or
absorption of it'll shut down a lot of
processes.
In this study
and uh they had a couple groups of rats
to one group they gave him uh them water
and sugar. Another one it was uh water,
sugar and food. Another one was uh
water, food, and cocaine.
And um ultimately, there's a fourth one,
but ultimately they found that the group
that had the water, um food, and
cocaine, the rats would eat or drink
some.
They would stop to eat or drink some.
The rats that had the sugar, uh, water
and food did not stop to take in water
or food.
That group died the fastest.
That's how addictive that's how
addictive sugar can be. So while sugar
itself in my opinion is um you useful uh
again like anything else it's it's in a
smaller dose um and you know many will
say if you're somewhere around the 20 um
20 gram mark um I've seen 20 to 40 but
man you start pushing that 40 I'd stop
and really look at what you're eating
and why you're eating it and um how the
body processes. If your body is made up
of proteins and fats,
uh you know, like our pyramid, and we've
turned our pyramid around to where it
says 65% of what we eat needs to be
carbohydrates.
As we know, technology is showing us
something completely different. And when
you eat like that, your body will show
you. And I mean, it sure shows me. I
know when I've eaten too much. Our
body's talking, but we haven't been
taught to listen. [laughter]
Well, I I know that from experience. I
remember when the the larger part of the
pyramid were your proteins and your
dairy and then when they turned it into
the whole grains. It sounds good
and I did it thinking that that's what
was good for me.
>> Yeah. But that just increased my
downhill
more than a slide was like a race to
poor health.
>> Yeah.
with many of us and and then you know
they started opening clinics uh you know
why are you eating so much of these bad
foods and you know there's a
psychological and please don't
misunderstand me not that there can't be
an emotional component to why you might
be eating a certain way but if you take
a look at just that one piece of
research and you begin to recognize how
addictive,
you know, sugars are. And then of course
we have um companies that
uh without, you know, naming one that
had some yellow arches, uh I believe
they were one of the first to put a
little sugar water brush on the buns
because
it tasted good. We wanted more.
And then there's the slide factor. Does
anybody know about that?
>> You know what factor?
>> The slide factor. I mean, they they have
all of these scientists that, you know,
you've got this group that's that's um
concentrating on the sugar content, the
content that would laz potato chips. You
just can't eat one. I understand they
were one of the first to actually put
real salt on some of their things
because guess what? We started craving
that or your body will crave that good
stuff, right? Or uh you know they do it
with sugars. Um and uh but the slide
factor again scientists over in another
group, how quickly and easily does it
slide down the back of the throat?
That's actually a thing. And and and
it's rated food will be rated for its
slide factor.
>> Gotcha. The SL Now I understand the
>> Well, Ivon, we've got
>> all of that causing to more pain.
>> All of that. Yeah. Goes down easy and
yeah, just in the out in in the long run
that easy is not necessarily what's best
for us.
Well, we do have questions coming in.
So, I want to make sure that we leave
some time for questions and getting a
few answers. I know there's so much that
we can share and go more into this
topic, which we do want you to come back
and we can continue this conversation.
Absolutely.
Absolutely want you to come back. So,
James is wanting to know if under 20
grams of raw sugar. Okay. Now, that
depends on what else he's eating, right?
[laughter]
>> Um, so, uh, I would certainly look at,
is he asking under 20 is okay or within
20? I I I key in on words.
>> Under 20 grams of raw sugar okay.
>> Is 20 grams? You know, the there are
many that say you want to stay under 20
or at 20. Don't exceed 20. Um, obviously
your body does need certain sugars for
um as an energy source. Again, that's
going to be based on your workload. You
you know, think about this. a somebody
who's sitting at a computer, a librarian
is not going to be required the same
energy resources that um uh a nurse
might be required as she's making her
rounds, a construction worker, an
athlete, they will be required more. So,
think about the work load that you're
taking in for the day. I personally try
to stay at or below 20. Um, and that's
helped me to maintain uh my weight loss
when I did change from the higher carb
uh uh food sources that I was eating. Uh
when I started adding nutrition, uh I'll
tell you my cupboards changed. I mean
like in five or six months you could
open my cupboards and because when you
satiate the body you'll find that that
sugar that you're talking about you just
don't have the same desire for I can
walk by a tray especially during the
holidays
and if I've been taking in my nutrition
regularly and and that includes protein
you will find that I might grab one
whereas four. I might have grabbed three
or four here and walked back for two
more. [laughter]
Life's too short to eat dessert f was
first was was my motto.
Yes. Yes. It was mine for quite some
time as well. You know, it's crazy
different people's thoughts on food and
and the the way that they consume food
and and what where their importance and
priorities are. I have three four
refrigerators in my home and uh two
kitchens and my kitchen
is totally different than the other.
Totally different. Yet I spend less
money on food. So just because I don't
like all that junk and clutter
cluttering up my body.
>> Well, and when you stay away from it,
you certainly start to feel it again.
>> Oh, absolutely. Absolutely.
Let's go ahead and go to the first
question and that is AJ with his hand
up. Hello AJ.
>> Hey Ivon, how are you?
>> Hey, fantastic. Good to see you.
>> You you you know that you're among my
favorite people on the planet. I like
Dan, too.
>> So,
it's uh it's really good to have you on
the show. My my question has to do with
uh some of the procedures that you do uh
in your practice that help uh different
things.
>> Sure.
>> I'm going to describe a few of these
things and I want you to tell us how you
help people. Uh one is kind of like the
dowages hump.
One is the scoliosis and the other I
don't know what it's called the the but
I think the technical term is crooked
toe.
>> Hammer toe
>> is that is is that a hammer toe? Is that
>> hammer toe or mallet toe are often used?
>> Oh, so that's that's what that Okay. So
number one, what are the techniques that
you use? And two, about how long does it
take uh an average person to get relief?
>> Okay. So, if we're talking about pain
relief, um when I'm using my
microcurrent, it'll be while you're in
office. We'll drop your pain, I'll say
nine out of 10 will have a a drop in
pain by half or greater in the same
session. uh we're working on the
electrical of the body and we're moving
calcium ion channels and um we're
tapping into your electrical which then
will move things differently than the
chemical of the body works and so we can
very quickly drop inflammation.
Now we want to get to the root cause but
for dowingers hump there'll be a pain
relief within the same day. The typical
that I see dowardgers hump might be
three sessions
uh for
explain what you just said that means
someone with a doward hump would be
walking straighter in three sessions. So
Dowinger's hump also known as the
widow's hump. Today we call it tech neck
for technology. You know many of us are
like this and that C7 becomes stressed.
Ultimately what we see happening is that
stress point the body wants to come
bring um nutrients to uh and many people
with endowingers have um either
osteopenia, osteoporosis.
So those bones uh will begin to develop
hairline fractures and or it could be um
addressing the tendons which is on
either side of that vertebrae. Either
way, what type of tissue issue is it?
Do you know
>> inflammation?
>> Hard tissue. Yeah. Sorry about that. I
just had to throw I just had to throw
that in there. So we're dealing with
we're dealing with hard tissue. We
really are. Um but you know again the
causation is this constant stress um
right here on C7. So I will take my wand
and um my handy dandy NASA tool and we
just um go over the area. We will also
this is has a computer chip. It also has
a um like a uh um an EKG right. It
attaches uh it finds electrical blocks.
So much like an electrician um excuse
me, an electrician will go in and use
his volt or ohm meter to check the
outlet on your wall. Is there any
electrical
um resistance or blocks going to the box
outside the house and back? That's
exactly what I do. But I'm going from
the tissue issue
to the brain and back. And then we get
the brain involved also because when the
brain's involved, healing happens
faster. So a dowingers hump depending
upon how old it is, how large it is, and
how many of the vertebrae it typically
starts on C7 and will extend to either
side. um you know usually within about
three sessions. Um for mallettoe
uh again kind of the same thing. What
you're looking at is damage happening
that uh to the tissue. The tissue is
literally degragating. Often times it's
pulling kind of like uh when you get um
uh um oh
where trigger finger and what's the
other one? Um
it'll come back to me but you also get
it on your feet. It's called planners
fasciitis. that tendon work is instead
of becoming loosey goosey like with
scoliosis,
it gets tight and taunt and short and so
with mallettoe it causes it to move
curve eventually some of them will
overlap each other and then same kind of
a thing we'll come in with our device
and we First address the inflammation.
Second will address any scar tissue
because inflammation and scar tissue
both
um are an electrical block. Electrical
cannot go through them. So what happens
is they'll go around them. So it's not
addressing it. So that's the first thing
we do is um address in that way. And
then did you ask about scoliosis also?
>> Most importantly. Yeah. So, scoliosis,
very interesting. Here's how we're
taught. And it's going to be oftentimes
people look at me like I'm crazy, but I
have over a hundred scoliosis that I've
been able to help correct. And nutrition
does the rebuild so that the body
doesn't go back to
um that state. But I want you just to
visualize your spine. Ligaments go bone
to bone. Okay? So oftent times, first
the ligaments start to degragate. So
remember I just said loosey goosey. All
right? So now they're a little bit
sloppy. And then you have tension on the
muscles. The muscles on either side of
the spine are playing this tugof-war
game. Okay?
And because your spine is loosey goosey,
you've got the ligaments and then you've
got the tendons that become um I'm going
to use the word loose. Uh it it will the
muscle will pull and shift those
vertebrae out of alignment.
And I've worked with people that had,
you know, uh 54
uh degree curvature, 57 degree
curvature. Um and we've been able, that
took about 8 to 10 sessions. Uh but we
were able to straighten the spine back
up. Uh she um stayed on the nutrition
for some time and then actually she
thought she was well and she was. uh she
went back to kind of her old eating
habits. She did come back in to see me
as things started to shift again and I
think now she understands what rebuild
means.
>> Um and ju just because somebody I think
they put their hand down or uh but
and thank you for that. Um but
so h how how does that kind of relate to
an Achilles tendon?
Well, Achilles tendon in my opinion is
much like um oh it's called dupetrins
remember I was trying to remember
>> contraction dupetrins contraure again
that tendon is pulling tight and taunt
and that's uh what achilles tendon is
happening as well ultimately it is a
muscle connective tissue issue as doc
would call it a hard tissue issue
>> and what did a what did aut nutrients
involved here.
>> Well, um in addition to your essential
90 plus, I would add glucosamine,
strontium,
um uh uh oh, I love MSM.
Uh MSM has so it it will aid in healing
faster. It's got many properties, but it
will definitely aid in healing faster.
So uh but um yeah outside so your
essentials and then I would do um an
extra dose of those.
>> Awesome. So that so strontium is found
in the osteo effects. There's the MSM
Ultra that has the MSM um which are
things that I took and I personally have
been treated by Ivonne and I wish that I
lived closer or that I was able to get
those eight treatments. But Ivonne,
there were times where I had things out
and you drew lines on my back and just
after that one session you could see the
improvements.
>> Yeah, at some point we should show those
uh those slides because you know
>> we we'll do that
>> to to get a visual.
>> Yes, to get a visual because scoliosis
has been one of the things that really
affected my confidence.
>> Yeah. Well, and I've got several on my,
you know, between my website and my
Facebook. So, uh I I even have a live
one that's I don't know, it's probably
six years old, but it's somewhere in
that Facebook.
>> You can see the process.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so, Bill, did you have a question? We
are at the top of the hour. We need to
be respectful of time of everybody who's
here with us. Um Bill, if you could
unmute, that would be great. if you had
a quick question.
>> I was only going to ask about the
zytoscans aidology and hair on us mere
mortals that cannot get to her. I could
but our listening audience
zytocan
uh parodology and hair analysis is that
any part of your practice?
>> So um I I I have a couple different
scans. I do own and uh use the zyto scan
and then I have some others for their
full body scans. Um while I do not do
iridology
uh or what was the other one that you
said?
>> He just said iridology zyo or hair
analysis.
>> Oh, and so I do not do irriidology, but
I do have somebody locally. They're
about 50 miles from me that does um they
do that. And then the um hair analysis,
all my clients um I send straight to Dr.
Milan uh in San Diego and uh then we can
read those reports when they get back.
So great question. Thank you.
Well, and those are all things that help
us to to know where somebody is
nutritionally,
where where things are are disconnected
so that we as certified holistic health
coaches or health advocates, functional
medicine practitioners can then know
where to start and then also have that
as a way to monitor progress.
So, um, but great question, Bill, and
for those that are that can get to this,
uh, Sacramento area,
definitely
look upon. So, Ivonne, how can people
reach you?
Um, well, I can give you my website. Uh,
that is the number four, a
betteryou2.com.
and or you can my office line is 916-990
and I'm on Facebook. I'm I'm not a, you
know, a social media person, but I try
to do my best. And I I have some live um
uh sessions in there, so you can get a
little idea of what microcurrent looks
like and how it might, you know, benefit
you. Ultimately though, um none of the
tools that I have can replace missing
tissue. And I want you to understand how
important uh nutrition is. And you know,
I I was talking to somebody about this
this morning. Um, you know, if you
believe like I do, God said, "From the
ground I drew you."
And in the soil is over 80 nutrients.
And to date, right now, technology tells
us, you know, that we need 60. I think
when technology catches up, uh, they're
going to we're going to know we're going
to know that we know we need all of
those minerals that are in the soil. And
same with the microbiome.
You know, to date, something like half
of what they found is in our body. I
think that's just a beautiful site.
>> And that's just not once or twice a year
or a month or even a week.
>> Oh, that's
daily. Yeah. Thank you for pointing that
out. Absolutely. That is daily. We we
need those nutrients if you want to
rebuild. Otherwise, you know, you can
certainly treat a symptom, but if it's
the symptom that's going to just keep
coming back, you know, uh why bother?
>> Absolutely. Do you have time for one
more question?
>> I do. Thank you.
>> All right, Nancy, go ahead and unmute
yourself.
Oh, I'm I'm sorry. I could I could get
it online. I just have a friend 80 years
old, severe arthritis, deformed hands,
and so we can get to California even
though we're in Florida. So, is that is
that something that would be
uh reasonable to expect to be out there
for a month and have have an improvement
on her?
Well, to be honest with you, in my
opinion, unless there's something that I
don't know about and we can certainly do
a history over the phone, um if you are
already, you know, um on the nutritional
program,
uh that should be able to resolve it. It
may not be quite as swiftly,
uh but nutrition ultimately will be what
you know I would recommend. Otherwise,
uh you can reach out to me. I there are
colleagues that are out on the east
coast and uh you know you don't need to
come out here for a month. Worst case
scenario, you can you know purchase a
home device
>> and um it would be a whole lot less than
you coming out here.
>> Well, she's from California.
>> Oh, okay.
>> She and she just she's only been here
for a couple years
and um but yeah. Okay. So, that was the
thing. But I I will I will look you up
on on that website. But because I have
been on the program for almost three
months now, and I feel like my I'm not
on it for arthritic pain, but I but I've
been feel I feel like my arthritic pain
has not been as it's been disappointing.
Now, my husband's great. His was
fantastic. And he doesn't even he he
doesn't even take premium product. But
um um but um but anyway, so I will be
looking you up. Thank you for your time.
>> And I just put my website in the chat.
Um and I'm happy to answer your
questions.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much for that. And
Nancy, it does take time. So we're
breakdown did not occur overnight or
even in a few months. Maybe the pain
suddenly. It took many years in order to
get there. So, not that it's going to
take years to get back, but it
absolutely does take consistency and it
does take time. Ivonne, thank you so
much for being here with us today and we
look forward to having you on again as
we go more into um pain and I want to
hit those neurotransmitters
>> and whatffects
the brain.
>> Absolutely. Let's rebuild. Let's get
people happier and healthier and yeah,
let them know what what is possible,
what is available.
>> Absolutely. Thank you so much. And if I
could get my co-hosts on with me um as I
would not be able to do this without
them and I just appreciate them so very
much. I have Marilyn here. She is very
very busy with her fingers and keeping
her nutrition going to keep her fingers
going. Um, as if you're here live with
us and you have that chat open, you will
see that she is taking notes and
transcribing what is being said and
putting it there. So folks, if you're
watching us on the live stream or on a
replay somewhere and you want to be able
to see notes because you're not able to
take them fast enough, Marilyn does a
fantastic job to help you out with that.
You can join us here Monday through
Friday from 12 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific
time, 1 to 2 Mountain, 2 to 3 Central, 3
to 4 Eastern, or is it 900 p.m. to 10:00
p.m.
in South Africa or it's 8 to 9? I don't
time changes. But anyways, um thank you
so much Marilyn for all you do. Um, we
have one of the newest members to our
tech team and that is Kaylee. Kayleie's
joining us as a a student bringing her
knowledge in technology
in helping us with the show. So, thank
you so much, Kaylee, for being here with
us. And we have Ruth Ellen, our
executive production manager, helping to
keep the stream um or pull it all
together so that it can go out so that
you that are watching the replay or
watching the live stream on another
platform see it in its entirety. Thank
you so much, Ruth Ellen. And we have Rod
who is helping keep an eye on things and
getting some traction and communications
going out on those different social
media platforms to help bring awareness
to the show and bringing out points like
Ivonne is amazing and is so
knowledgeable and helpful. So yes, she
absolutely is.
And we have Albert who is our um head
bouncer letting people into the Zoom
room. And that's a good thing folks.
Okay, we put you in the waiting room. We
let you in as there are some people that
don't want this information to be
shared. So we want to make sure that we
keep this as a family safe environment
so that everybody can just focus on the
content and learning what it is needed
for them to create that better health
journey and to share it with others. And
then we also have oh so thank you
Albert. We also have AJ. AJ has been
very um the driving force to getting out
on all these different platforms as we
want to make sure that we're meeting
people where they're at. So, as the
director of digital marketing, he has
been very instrumental in helping make
that happen and is the reason why Kaylee
is here today with us to help. So,
folks, thank you so much for joining us
here on Daily with Doc. Thank you Dr.
Wallik for being here with us as well.
Greatly appreciate you and we will see
you Wednesday and Thursday of most weeks
including this week. Tomorrow we have
Dr. Laura Dennison joining us. So make
sure that you tune in folks. Mark it on
your calendar. Same place, same time.
Zoom dodailywithdoc.com.
That's zoom dot period
dailywithdoceriod.com.
COM, we are here for you. My name is
Becca Dukes. Thank you so much again for
joining us here on Daily with Doc and
Becca. If you'd like to know more about
nutrition and about becoming a certified
holistic health coach, make sure that
you check out Coach.dwithdoc.com
dailywithdoc.com
where you'll find a twominute video that
shares the importance and the future of
being a certified holistic health coach
and the need for it because folks many
doctors are coming out and admitting
that they did not learn about nutrition
in school. We learned through Dr. for
Wallik's research, it is essential
to be able to go from just barely
surviving
or not surviving at all to thriving. So
until next time, we'll see you later
everybody. Thank you again for joining
us here. Bye for now.
Thank you.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is [music] for educational
purposes only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music] are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health or income.
As an empowered individual, [music]
you do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding [music]
father of the science of epigenetics
guiding us with the best options to
obtain or maintain optimal health, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Welcome to Daily Daily with [music] Doc
and Becca. This program is for
educational purposes only. The
statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music] are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health [music] or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallik.